I had no idea they were negotiating with
Stephen Crowder again not my business I
came into work one day suddenly Brett
Cooper was there not my business I don't
know who they're hiring I don't own the
company right but what I started getting
was after I had dropped my podcast in
the comments section everyone was
basically tearing me apart being like
blink twice if you need help first thing
like I'm a hostage situation or saying
what if you don't say anything about
Stephen Crowder you're a fraud you're a
fraud just like suddenly you're a fraud
you're a fraud so I go and I watch this
video and just like everybody else
watching it live his first video your
instincts are like whoa he's throwing
some bombs he's calling it big con he's
saying essentially that we are enslaved
by these contract terms he actually uses
the term enslavement if you don't want
to be a slave you know you may be a
co-worker I'm going to figure it out for
all of us like you're a hero you're a
martyr and because I was getting so many
comments the first thing I did was that
I messaged my EP and I said we have to
cover this tomorrow on the show because
now everyone thinks I'm a fraud and they
think that I've signed with fraudulent
or slave-like terms and that's so
totally unfair to me so my interest in
this is that it hit me and it hit
everybody else the daily wire and it was
unfair